hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the 11th of August today and your
children to gain sweat news first up
we're getting some idea of what to
expect from uncharted 4 on the ps4
Naughty Dog's Neil druckmann has said
their previous projects have taught them
that they want to make uncharted for
more personal than the series as earlier
installments he explains we've learned a
lot about how we tell stories through
interactivity with the last of us and
there are lessons that we're applying to
uncharted 4 it's about finding that
right balance for uncharted it's
definitely not going to be the last of
us but we are trying to make it more
personal this time and see how much we
can delve into who nathan drake really
is and what kind of effect this journey
has on him and the people around him
nonetheless uncharted being what it is
will still very much retain that summer
movie blockbuster feel the dev intends
for it to keep its fun flavor while
weaving set pieces into the narrative EA
access has now officially hit the market
after exiting beta of the Xbox one the
five dollars a month or thirty dollars a
year subscription based program will let
you play any game in EAS vault thus far
that vault includes fever 14 madden NFL
25 peggle two and battlefield 4 but more
titles will be added in future there's
also ten percent off Xbox one EA games
for subscribers and access to demos
speaking of which madden NFL 25 a game
that has become known for always having
a demo available will now only be
releasing it through EA access suffice
it to say people aren't so happy about
that one call duty advanced warfare
drops their multiplayer reveal a short
while ago and here's what you might want
to know there are loads of EXO abilities
including cloaking shield cover and
launcher a super punch that lets you
punch an enemy to death a boost jump
air-to-ground mele attack called slam
and bustier Dodgers dashes and slides
player customization will still focus on
XP aesthetic customization is available
and you can access a virtual firing
range players can get supply drops from
in gay
challenges and time played which
consists of weapons and loads of other
cool crap day one will offer up 12
multiplayer modes with capture the flag
Search and Destroy and hard point all
returning the four maps announced today
were bio lab riot ascend and defender
like all modern first-person shooters
there will be dynamic elements instead
maps although Activision are yet to
reveal whether or not they've managed to
think of a silly name for it to compete
against battlefields LEvolution take a
look at the rest of the details on site
and let me know if you think advanced
warfare is going to be your thing that
is it for me today i'll be back seems
I'm tomorrow with a bunch more news